now u.s secretary of state anthony
blinken is in tel aviv at the start of a
mideast
tour the visit is designed to
consolidate the ceasefire between israel
and hamas militants in the gaza strip
blinking is holding talks with israeli
leaders before traveling to meet with
leaders of the palestinian authority
jordan and egypt in a bid to open the
flow of humanitarian aid into gaza
the territory was devastated by israeli
airstrikes launched in retribution for
hamas rocket attacks on israeli cities
at a press conference with israel's
prime minister benjamin netanyahu
blinken appealed for humanity and
empathy especially in times of conflict
losses on both sides were profound
casualties are often reduced to numbers
but behind every number is an individual
human being a daughter a son
a father a mother a grandparent a best
friend
and as the talmud teaches to lose a life
is to lose the whole world whether that
life is palestinian or israeli
now at that same press conference
israel's prime minister benjamin
netanyahu emphasized the need for
international cooperation to ensure
stability in the region
we need to work together to expand
normalization between israel
and arab and the muslim world
and deep in the peace treaties that we
already have
we discussed also how to
improve the lives and the conditions of
the palestinians the humanitarian
conditions
in gaza as well as building economic
growth
for judea samaria the west bank
with the international cooperation
and participation our correspondent
tanya kramer is following this story for
us and she joins us from jerusalem hi
tanya
what more can you tell us about what
anthony blinken and benjamin
netanyahu have been saying
well the israeli prime minister benimi
netanyahu first of all thanked
the american administration u.s
president joe biden
for the support uh in israel's right to
defend itself that was very important to
him
as a second point already then he talked
about the iran
nuclear deal he said he hopes that the
u.s
would not go back to the old
nuclear deal that is currently discussed
with the international
community and what we just heard also in
the uh
from prime minister netanyahu talked
about peace but mainly peace with the
arab nations the abrahamic courts he was
referring to
but also he talked about the
humanitarian situation in gaza
and he conditioned that that it needs to
get better there but he conditioned that
also on the return of
the missing soldiers and also the two
israelis that are held in
that are being held in gaza now anthony
blinken the u.s secretary of state
addressed more the humanitarian
situation he said it's a very
difficult situation in gaza and that he
would
make a major announcement on
rehabilitation and rebuilding gaza
but also the need to make sure that this
doesn't benefit hamas
and he only brushed the issue of the
iran nuclear deal
very very briefly we know that he wants
to stabilize
the ceasefire that's in place but tanya
looking ahead is it realistic to expect
any steps towards israeli-palestinian
peace talks
well that's actually the question here
because at the moment the focus seems to
be to securing
the ceasefire that was broken by egypt
between hamas and
israel and to focus on rehabilitation or
reconstruction of gaza that is a very
that is needed there needs to be also
you know discussion about
a mechanism to bring in uh for example
building materials so we are there at
the very very beginning of this
although the u.s secretary of state
anthony blinken addressed
he said you know there needs to be an
address of the
underlying causes for this conflict but
you know we didn't get a sense that
anything is being done
in this regard to to find also a
political
uh uh solution to all of this we have
here at the very beginning it seems
and at the same time we understand also
it's important for the american
administration at least
you know to re-strengthen ties with the
palestinian authority
in the occupied west bank he's going to
meet the palestinian president mahmoud
abbas now in the afternoon
because these ties had been strained
under the trump administration
our correspondent tanya kramer reporting
from jerusalem thank you